[Music]
many of us know the Disney movie
Hercules as a feel-good story about a
hunky Greek god who outsmarted Hades and
swept mogera off her feet literally but
the real story is one of revenge madness
and savage battles new here be sure to
subscribe to the things to be up to
speed with our new videos and click the
like button if you enjoyed this video
now here is the disturbing real story
behind his knees Hercules the movie
version Hercules is the most beloved
hero in Greek and Roman mythology but he
wasn't exactly the perfect lovable
character we know from the Disney film
in the Disney version of the story
Hercules was born as the beloved child
of Hera and Zeus then Hades got his
hands on baby Hercules he enlisted his
henchmen to feed him a bottle of
mortality juice with the intent of
turning him into a mortal luckily for
Hercules the henchmen failed to feed him
the very last drop of elixir leaving him
as a demigod who retained his superhuman
strength because he was now part human
he could not join his parents Zeus and
Hera in Olympus in order to gain his
gods status back he was charged with
performing heroic feats only then could
he take his place among the rest of the
gods in Olympus but all of his
impressive acts fell short of true
heroism then he met the sassy gal pal of
Hades mogera
sparks flew monsters flew they fell in
love and he sacrificed himself to stay
for life
this made Hercules a true hero and his
gods status was restored he was welcomed
back to Olympus but he decided to stay
back in the human world with mogera such
a sweet story but the real mythology is
far more disturbing and dark the real
mythology so you know how the movie
shows Zeus and Hera as the loving
parents of Hercules that's not exactly
how the real story goes
apparently Zeus had a reputation for
cheating on Hera with mortal women
according to legend Zeus fell for a
gorgeous woman named Al Kamini
since Zeus had supernatural powers he
transformed himself to look like Al
Khomeini's husband and they got busy
talk about how creepy during their
undercover under sheeps dance
used impregnated alchemy knee thus
Hercules was born as a half mortal half
God with a human mother Zeus is his
father and one goddess who was super
ticked off at his existence Hera was
furious with Zeus she wanted to go all
Beyonce on him but she knew she wasn't
powerful enough to defeat the god of the
sky so she did - Hercules his life what
Beyonce did to that car she messed it up
Hera made that poor dude suffer
throughout his entire mortal life
seriously that is one vindictive goddess
first she sent a bunch of snakes into
his crib to attack little baby Hercules
since Hercules with half God he had
super strong baby muscles he strangled
the snakes one in each hand and shook
them like rattles before they can bite
him later
Hercules fell in love with mogera butts
who got married and started a family
they had three sons and things seemed to
be going pretty well until boom Hera got
to work the legends say that Harrison -
fit of madness into Hercules he flipped
out in a huge rage and ended the lives
of mogera and their children he didn't
even know what he was doing when he
snapped out of it he was so horrified he
went to the god Apollo for advice not
exactly like the sweet innocent Disney
version is it anyway Apollo told
Hercules to go to the city Kieran's
and redeem himself by performing 12
heroic acts this city had a mean king
named Yuri thoses Hercules had to serve
this king for 12 years and do it over
the king asked him while he was paying
off his debt to the gods
Apollo promised Hercules that after he
completed all 12 noble deeds he would be
immortal and be able to go to Olympus
the 12 labors the cruel King Eurystheus
ordered Hercules to do some pretty crazy
stuff he ordered him to kill a lion with
a club destroy a nine headed water
serpent still the goddess Diana's pet
Red Deer and bring the king this huge
erymanthian boar with a major bad temper
alive here's the part where Hercules is
shining Disney image may get a little
tarnished when Hercules went to the
mountain to find the boar on his way he
stopped to visit his scent our friend
fullest centaurs are creatures who have
a man's head and a torso of a horse's
legs and tail pholis made Hercules a
meal and they hung out and ate some
dinner
Hercules asked bolas
if he could have some of his wine but
pholis was afraid to open the wine jug
because it was the community wine and
belonged to all the Centaurs being the
rude dinner guest that he was he told
foulest not to worry and open to the jug
himself the Centaurs must have a serious
nose for wine because they smelled the
open jug and came running they were
seriously ticked off that Hercules was
drinking their wine they attacked
Hercules with rocks and fir trees and
what did Hercules do instead of saying
he was sorry he started picking off
centaurs by shooting poisoned arrows at
them his buddy pholis was confused as to
why all his pals were dying so quickly
from a seemingly small arrow wound so he
pulled the poison arrow out of his
friend to check it out then foulest
accidentally dropped the arrow
puncturing his foot and he died some
friend Hercules was remind us not to
have him over for pot roasts anytime
soon after that Eurystheus told hercules
to steal some guys cattle and clean
another guy stables chase away some
annoying scary birds and capture an
angry destructive bull only for the king
to release it and let it wreak havoc in
the city then Hercules had to capture
these man-eating horses and steal the
polities belt if you've seen Wonder
Woman you know it would not be wise to
mess with apology she was Queen of the
Amazons the tribe of women warriors who
taught Wonder Woman how to fight when
Hercules stole her belt he caused a huge
battle between his army and the Amazons
he totally got away with stealing her
belt and brought it back to the crazy
king seriously what kind of wackadoo
King would request this kind of stuff
the most insidious request from the king
was asking him to steal those golden
apples that Hera the goddess who hated
him gave to Zeus not an easy task but
Hercules managed to pull it off he
tricked Atlas into helping him the dude
while holding the world the most
impossible of the deeds was the final
one Hercules had to go down in kidnap
Cerberus the beast who guards the gates
of Hades underworld he finally completed
all 12 heroic deeds so you think he
would be all good right wrong he went on
to be tortured even more by Hera until
she finally led up on the poor guy after
being poisoned and burned Hera and Zeus
brought Hercules up to Olympus to become
a God and that's the real story behind
Hercules thanks so much for watching the
things see you next time
[Music]